all right you caught me the hair this
trying to look like that before this
review came up but it's the best I could
do in short notice at least I'm trying
Dumb and Dumber to look the way that's
spelled there's just nothing else after
it so dumb endeavor to is a sequel
finally to Dumb and Dumber 20 years
later 20 years for us and 20 years for
them I love it when it works out like
that in Dumb & Dumber to Lloyd's been
catatonic for like 20 years you saw this
in the trailer Harry comes and visits
Herman and Lloyds I got ya it's all been
a joke but Harry has a daughter he
didn't know about so they go on this
road trip to go see her and then now
shenanigans another Dumb and Dumber road
trip shenanigan movie I give this movie
credit while also backing up and going
well you people are gonna have a
complaint about it I imagine people will
be like it's copping the first movie to
a point it is so I guess if it ain't
broke don't fix it even after 20 years
no getting right into it Jim Carrey Jeff
Daniels they kill it together these two
have absurdly great chemistry they have
great comedic timing
I don't naturally see Jeff Daniels as a
comedic actor especially not that
physical comedy that Jim Carrey is known
for but he keeps up will McAvoy ladies
and gentlemen he's gone for this it's
not only great to see them on-screen
together again but it's great to see Jim
Carrey back at doing what he's great at
I mean Jim Carrey as comedic actor
that's what made him knows how we all
know who he is today
it didn't feel old he certainly didn't
look rusty at it it was great I kind of
died I describe it as imagine old Jim
Kirk sitting in a captain's chair of the
enterprise again he's like yeah I
remember that [ __ ] he feels that power
that's Jim Carrey in this movie
now Dumb and Dumber is a nostalgic cult
classic to a lot of people so they're
gonna compare this movie to that
nostalgia is a funny thing
it makes you love something but it makes
you love it so much that anything that
comes after is just an automatically not
as good and it's tough for a movie like
this to compete with something like that
the thing that put the franchise on the
map is the thing that's actually kind of
hard for the sequel to breakthrough but
I gotta say this movie had me in tears
on more than a few occasions and
watching the first movie right before I
saw the second movie I was able to just
go springboard from one to the other so
I can be like okay how are they is it
like they're rusty is like they're
really old dudes trying to be their
young selves or is it just seamless and
you go right into it I felt was pretty
seamless because we don't want to be
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull Don this
one we don't want to be reminded a
hundred times
over that there old guys now other than
a couple references to them being old
for the most part they're just like yeah
we're just mentally young and we're just
doing our young guy physical comedy [ __ ]
that we did in the first movie that you
all loved us for even the fart jokes I
laughed at I never laugh at fart jokes I
always consider them the lowest common
denominator like the writers like oh we
got it we got to make someone Chuck all
no one's laugh cuz there haven't been
giant fart jokes not always guaranteed
laugh in fact I never laugh at that [ __ ]
this movie I laughed at them what can I
say the movie had a couple of weak spots
Minh Harry's daughter the one that
they're trying to go find it was
ultimately she's pretty simple I don't
mean simple I was like she's Harry's
daughter but she is there just like we
need a hot chick to act ditzy boom done
really any model could have filled her
shoot I mean she she is odd for sure you
probably find me quoted the new Facebook
post tomorrow title Jeremy proves all
men are pigs up for now hell there's
girls yeah we really shouldn't
contribute much to the comedy in the
movie but I really don't want everyone
to have to contribute to the comedy in
the movie Harry and Lloyd need to make
me laugh everyone else I mean if they
make me laugh that's a nice bonus and I
don't know what it is about third acts
and comedies but usually the weakest
part of most comedies example like Ted
with the Giovanni Ribisi thing it's just
something that's so different than the
rest of the movie I kind of attribute it
as the strength and a comedy is the pack
getting to the end not the actual
achieving the end itself it's like rock
climbing going on the adventures like oh
yeah that's the cool part then you
plateau and you're like oh it's not that
exciting anymore that plateau feelings
cut it a third act of this comedy and a
lot of other comedies I've seen in the
end um and number two was what I wanted
Dumb and Dumber to to be but it was
funnier than what I thought it could be
Jeff Daniels and Jim Carrey Thor magic
it's great to see that they have it lost
it's great to see them play to their
strengths is great to see Jim Carrey
back in that role I will certainly say
Dumb and Dumber 2 is a really good time
no alcohol required apparently I just
like really dumb humor sometimes so Dumb
and Dumber - have you seen it what did
you think about it and this tells you
aside how did you feel compared to the
first movie whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more